hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast sterling and well and
Jess solutions for clinical the Gnostics
in the cloud
the team from BioPark genetics
laboratory will be the speakers for this
event beta is based at Guy's Hospital
London which leaves the South London NHS
genomic medicine centre we are excited
to bring you this educational webinar
presented by lab Rhodes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provide virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
hydrogen a leading global provider of
sample twinset solutions and DNAnexus
the leader in cloud-based genome
informatics and data management the
[ __ ] compliant in the nexus platform
provides seamless and secure integration
from the sequencer to Kaia GenBank
rheumatics tools where disease focus
researchers have a complete solution in
rapidly from raw data to valuable
insights and Alexander company signs
lead again the Nexus tinea and I'll be
your moderator for today's debate before
we begin I'd like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and that requests
them into the box that appears on screen
we answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please stick on they say
but located in the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits now
I'd like to introduce you to today's
speakers the team from bypass genetics
laboratories who will share insight into
how they implemented our automated
scalable install sufficient clinical
informatics pipelines in the cloud
including the team includes a Jew genome
informatics lead and rebound clinical
Fantasia and Mathias cancer clinical
scientists please join me in welcoming
the first speaker which you've booked I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
thanks Alessandro hi so as I just said
I'm work I'm the genome informatics lead
5 path genetics laboratory and I just
wanted to start things off here if I
give me a little bit of context about us
so we are the generation laboratories my
path which is based at Guy's Hospital
which is itself part of guidance at
Thomas's NHS Foundation Trust by path is
spun out of the NHS some years ago and
has is now one of the largest pathology
providers in the UK we have over 60
laboratories spread across four sites
mostly in and around London the genetics
labs works quite closely with the Claire
called genetics unit at Guy's Hospital
and we serve a population of around 6
million million people in the South East
of England we are the the main lab for
the South London genomic medicine center
as mentioned earlier which means we've
been taking a key role in the hundred
thousand genomes project which is
nothing in the UK over the last few
years and just sort of looking ahead
slightly we are expecting to increase
our activity as the genetic services in
the
moved to a new model of working a new
genomic medicine service and as part of
that we are again going to be a key the
poetry in that new set up and as a
result we will be seeing quite a lot
greater in our work I also wanted to
just talk about some of the benefits
that adopting the cloud genomics
platforms has given us as I said we are
growing at the moment and we are also
sort of collaborating and working closer
with other Liberace's in our region and
the cloud genomics platform has really
helped to standardize the by automatics
methods that we use across the various
labs by having everything in the cloud
it makes it very easy for all of our
various laboratories to access and use
the biometrics tools that we jointly
make available cloud is well known to
allow scalability and I just wanted to
point out that it this allows you to
scale both up and down and this elastic
collision can be very useful as your
minus costs directly reflect the
activity you have and you're not paying
for capacity that you are not using the
these platform server also helps us to
bring on new methods new algorithms you
it's a software etc in a very quick way
a lot of the infrastructure is there for
you and we can you take advantage of
that to let us concentrate on our sort
of area of expertise which is the by
Mattox and a lot of the sort of
information infrastructure is taking
care of you which allows us to bring
these new things are very quickly we
found that DNAnexus and hydrogen are
offer us a long-term solution we're
comfortable and confident that they are
not going to disappear next year and all
that has helped us to end up with an
accredited service to I say one pie
one eight nine standards we're very
happy that Danny Nexus and hydrogen are
global players taking part in various
label initiatives and also are able to
provide us the expertise that they have
gained from operating those various
different regions and finally the all
this sort of infrastructure that the
cloud genomics platforms give us will
allow us to very seamlessly expand into
other domains as they come into sort of
our scope for example playing court
trials we were recently looking at
sublingual trial work and and having the
these platforms in the cloud has allowed
us to tick all the boxes that the nickel
trials people need at least for the by
kinetics okay so I just want you to end
by acknowledging some people quickly the
genome informatics team who provide all
the BIOS pattex
for the genetics labs the egg same team
as well
the group of clinical scientists who are
interpreting all of the output from
those mathematics pipelines we work very
closely with the clinical genetics team
at guises Tomas's and obviously although
we are doing the diagnostic work the the
clinical side is hugely important and
especially when it comes to things like
multidisciplinary working which we need
to do to make the most of the new
genomic technologies that we are able to
be useful to education of patients and
it's very important that we work closely
to that with them and that's been going
very well and finally I just wanted to
mention the guys and some Thomas's
charity be very kindly were able to find
some of the early work to keep start the
xamp service great so I'm now going to
hand over to Andy he's going to talk a
bit more about five matters okay hi so
I'm Andy I'm one of the clinical bond
conditions working in the genome
six team and I just want to talk a
little bit about how we're using
DNAnexus some of the features have been
in excess and sort of how it suits our
needs is a growing chemical laboratory
so to start off I just kind of want to
give a an overview of how we get our
data from our sequences into ingenuity
variant analysis which is where
scientists will do their very own
interpretation so we have a couple of my
seats and a neck seat in the lab and
they they all are configured to output
their data to a local workstation and
over the network and that local
workstation is just a high spec PC with
Linux installed and once the data is
there we need to demultiplexer and to do
this we use PCL to ask you from Illumina
we were keen to automate this process
just to speed things up and make our
lives easier so we have a spritz on the
workstation that runs every hour and it
checks for any new run folders that come
off the sequencers and haven't been
demultiplexed and it will initiate
demultiplexing on that data and then we
have the next step is after
demultiplexing is that we need to upload
the fast key files into daily access so
that we can begin to process the data so
to do this again we wanted this to be
fully automated process and so we have
another script on the workstation again
runs hourly and this script will look
for any runs have been daemon
flexed and knead uploading interred in
INXS and if it finds one it will create
a DNAnexus project and the way it does
this is it uses some software called the
DX toolkit and I'll talk a bit more
about that in a following slide and then
once it's created the project it then
uses a piece of software called the
upload agent which is provided by Danny
Nexus and this is a command-line client
which is used to upload files into a
Danny access project and it has a number
of great features such as integrity
checking which is important for us
because we're handling patient data we
want to make sure that that date doesn't
get corrupted in any way when it's
uploaded it also has features such as it
will resume if the if the upload is
interrupted for any reason due to like
an network error I'm so that's important
when you're uploading a large quantity
of data and also it can perform parallel
uploads which speeds things up a lot ok
so oh so another thing I was going to
mention is that at some point we'd like
to look at streaming our data directly
from the sequences into barely in excess
so cutting out the local workstation
entirely and that's certainly something
we'd like to look in the future so once
our fast key files are in DNAnexus the
script that's running on our workstation
will then use the panel code that is in
the ASCII file names to determine which
one of our different pipelines that fast
queue needs to be run through in
DNAnexus and so so if we we essentially
have a config file and in that config
file every panel code is linked to one
of our three workflows we've got whole
exome sequencing worth
another workflow for our others have
smaller targeted panels and an oncology
workflow and that config file links each
code to work flow so that script knows
which workflow and should be used then
the script will set off the pipeline
three fast queue using a using the DX
toolkit which I mentioned previously
so the DX toolkit is a SDK software
development kit is provided by DNAnexus
and it essentially allows command line
access to pretty much all of da nexuses
features so that's great because it
means we can automate everything so you
can launch jobs monitor jobs build apps
SSH into jobs download files all sorts
of things using the X toolkit so that's
what we use to set off the pipeline's
and then once the pipeline's are set off
we then begin uploading the remaining
files from the run folder in today and
in XS we don't do that initially just to
speed things up because we won't start
processing the data as quickly as
possible so we just get the fast queues
up and get the pipeline's running and
then we upload the rest of the data
afterwards so the next step then I'll go
into a lot more detail about actual
pipelines and what they look like later
in this talk but at the end of each
pipeline and the VCF file will get
submitted into ingenuity very analysis I
mean I see using an app that is provided
by DNAnexus
and that means that our entire process
from sequencer to the bearings being
ready for analysis is seamlessly
automated doesn't require any hands-on
time at all which is great
so just to mention a bit more about
those pipelines so we have a whole exome
sequencing pipeline and this uses dragon
to get from fast cute BCF in ten minutes
and we traced about 30 samples per month
through this pipeline and then we have
another pipeline that uses for our sort
of small targeted panama's cheese bwa
and gatk 3 and with and we're processing
so well over a hundred samples every
month through this pipeline and then we
have another pipeline for our EGFR
oncology panel which uses blast gun and
verdicts DeBary calling and the sort of
thing that makes this pipeline staff and
the other two is how urgent the samples
are that go through this cancer samples
where the results from these tests can
in determine what treatments patients
might receive etc so we need to really
rapid turnaround time on these and so
we've got a pipeline that only takes 30
minutes and generally these runs are
self lay in the afternoon and the next
morning the variants are in ingenuity
ready for analysis and so it's very
quick turnaround ok so obviously as well
we are a diagnostic laboratory and we
handle patient data and therefore we
have quite strict rules that we have to
follow in terms of data security so we
needed to get down in excess assessed
and audited by by pant and guidance and
Thomas's trusts our IT security teams
and information governance teams to
demonstrate that Dan in excess was safe
for a strap load patient data - so we
don't upload any patient identifiable
information in our file names or
anything we
or sadhana mised and DNAnexus has a huge
number of inbuilt security features
which you can see some of them
summarized on this slide and they comply
with all sorts of information governance
regulations and legislation and that was
satisfied our IT security teams that
there was no problem with us uploading
our data into daily Nexus and this slide
just shows a few more of those features
so things like you know the data is
encrypted end-to-end so it's you know
it's all very secure which is great and
sort of relate to that we have a medical
laboratory we have to demonstrate that
we meet ISO one five one eight nine
standards which are the quality and
competent standards for medical
laboratories and so every year our lab
is inspected by you cats who the UK
accreditation service and they look at
all of our services and Rachel we're
meeting ISO one five one eight nine
standards and as part of this our
pipelines have been assessed and been
shown to meet I say one five one eight
nine standards and they form an integral
part of our accredited services so now I
want to talk a little bit more about
what a DNAnexus pipeline actually looks
like what is how how you would build one
how easy it is to use and some of the
features so the kind of core components
at all in access pipelines are apps and
apps are essentially standalone tools on
the data access platform I have defined
inputs and outputs so you might have an
app for bwa and a TA TK and outreach
tool that you would use as part of your
pipeline these
can be run from the command line using
Dax toolkit
or they can be run through the web
interface and each time you run an app
it will spin up a new virtual linux
server which will be of the system
requirements specifically for that app
and the app will run in that that Linux
worker and just each time that app is
launched and then this slide here just
kind of shows some of the configuration
options that you get with some of these
apps this is bwa there's a huge number
of settings you can change and you can
even if that's not enough you can add
additional command line options now as
well and you get a nice meeting me as
well there it explains how to use the
tool so there's lots of apps that are
provided sort of off the shelf by
DNAnexus or other third-party developers
which you can just install and use in
your pipelines immediately and some a
lot of these are open source as well
which means you can actually kind of
download the app modify and rebuild it
as you as you want and it was kind of
the availability of these pre-built apps
ready to go and then we could get up and
running really really quickly when we
first switched over to Danny Nexus so
some of the apps that we use
off-the-shelf things like fast QC BWAA
dak Picard and ingenuity variant
analysis that for submitting VCS into
ingenuity is in all our five lines but
you're not limited to the apps that are
available already you can build app to
yourself from scratch so we've built a
large number of apps ourselves and some
of these include things like Baskin
she's an asthmatic pipeline multi QC
which is a really nice QC tool which
aggregates QC data from other tools such
as fast kisi
verified by my deepa card etc and
produces a really nice report we have
apps for calculating coverage apps box
but nanopore data all sorts that we've
built ourselves so when we're building
apps we use the DX toolkit which is the
SDK da mentioned earlier and to build an
app you basically just have to provide
all the different components that would
be required to be packaged up by the DX
build command so this would include a
wrapper script in bash or Python
whatever other files or executables or
scripts you want to include and that
you'd want to be downloaded onto the
Linux worker that the the app will run
on package those up then you have like a
JSON file that will specify all of your
settings what inputs you have our
outfits you have what are the system
requirements for this app and that will
determine the specification of the Linux
worker that is spun out and also readme
file which will be displayed when
someone runs the app to explain how to
use it and this I mean this extremely
flexible you can build anything you want
it's got built-in support for things
like docker which we use in some apps
and as well as development is a spin of
cloud workstations which is really
useful if you just want to try out a new
tool or you just having play around and
you don't want to have to build a whole
app for it you can spin up a cloud
workstation association and do whatever
you want
so when we try to follow ACDs best
practice guidelines when well we do
follow ACDs best practice guidelines
when we're developing apps and so that's
the Association for clinical genetic
science here in the UK they set out a
lot of best practice guidelines for all
sort of sort of things that we do within
our genetics labs and this involves
version control of software
so all of our code or all of our apps is
version controlled in github it
undergoes code movie whenever we and
whenever we release a new version of
that we do a full validation on it
before we would actually put it into
production yes okay so apps kind of the
building blocks of our pipelines but to
actually turn apps into pipelines Wiis
workflows so DNAnexus workflow is
essentially a way of chaining different
apps together and linking the outputs of
absentee to the inputs of other apps so
that you get a pipeline and so we have a
workflow for each one of our pipelines
and like apps we version control our
workflows and so we have releases and we
we verify that they work before they be
rolled out to production say the
DNAnexus work those are pretty good
they're the nice features like apps for
example aren't dependent on each other
can run in parallel to save time so like
in this picture here this is our
oncology workflow and you can see here
that once the bomb fire will come out of
the amplifier flat stage and at that
point you can it starts bearing calling
with both our scan and verdict in
parallel because they're not dependent
on each other and for this pipeline it's
the BCF from Basco and we submit to
ingenuity so you can see of the BCF will
get submitted to ingenuity from Baskin
even though the verdict variant caller
is still running so it doesn't hold up
the results being available for analysis
okay so another great thing about
DNAnexus is the logging provides on the
alerts as well so in a DNAnexus project
we can see a log of everything that's
happened we can see all of the jobs that
were run we can see whether they
complete success
Lior not if they didn't you know you can
see things like the full command line
output from the app to help you with
debugging could see exactly what files
went into you and came out of each app
and how long they have stuck all sorts
of things and this provides essentially
a complete audit trail for our records
which is extremely important to have on
your clinical laboratory
it makes troubleshooting easier if
anything goes wrong and also we have
email alerts if any job fails and we've
actually configured it as well so that
we get slack notifications so if
anything goes wrong we can know about it
straight away and start trying to
resolve that so as we've mentioned one
of the great things about doing in
excess is its scalability before we were
using during access we were using a
university cluster and this had a number
of drawbacks we didn't have sufficient
privileges to install all the software
that we wanted we'd often have the jobs
of some type that we use for a long time
and it wasn't that reliable sometimes it
would go down halfway through a run and
DNAnexus
really solved all those problems for us
and there's as much compete as you need
available whenever you want it and you
can run huge numbers of jobs
simultaneously which is a great feature
whilst only paying for what you use is
very nice and then obviously with the
Dex toolkit and upload agent provides a
huge array of command line tools which
has allowed us to fully automate our
pipelines from end to end which is which
is really a game changer for us and as I
said it's really easy for us to build
new apps and workflows and through our
setup we can easily add the annals and
it's very nice development extremely
quick and easy
and another big big plus point is that
DNAnexus handled all of our data storage
so we don't have to worry about any
local hardware scoring data and DNAnexus
provides resilient cloud storage all of
our data from is easily and immediately
accessible from sort of our most recent
runs and for the older stuff we can used
alien access to archive it in Amazon
Glacia which provides low-cost long-term
resilience storage which is brilliant
and say but pretty much concludes what I
wanted to say so just to summarize we've
built a fast and fully automated
pipeline from sequencer to ingenuity
pipelines are a 1/5 of 189 accredited
the data security is great we extremely
scalable developing pipelines and apps
is really simple data storage got
resilient data storage and very detailed
logging and audit trails ok so I'm just
going to hand over to Matt and I will
tell you a bit more about the ingenuity
side of things
thank you apparently my name is Matt and
I'm a clinical scientist here in bypass
working on on the West team so welcome
to the ingenuity part of this
presentation a women using ingenuity now
for three years to analyze whole exome
sequencing the end results and during
those years there have been several
updates to ingenuity in particular the
female type labeled ranking
functionality during this webinar I will
describe how we use ingenuity in an
efficient manner to optimize our flow
through of cases
and of course how we use available
features to maximize our diagnostic rate
I will then present a few clinical case
studies as examples of the percent good
features and our West service is
accredited a to ISO standards with
flexible scope enabling us to create
bespoke panels for each case without
having to validate the genes and panels
beforehand for internal cases from our
local chemical genetics department we
use an electronic request system in our
in-house system called Nokia in the
system the clinicians log in and make
the request and choose the panels and
genes they want analyzed external
referrals are Santos in paper form
together the sample a clinicians can
choose a primary panel and a secondary
panel and the secondary panel is often
an expansion of the primary panel or may
cover a different aspect of the
patient's phenotype the gene panels are
then exported from Nokia to enable easy
and accurate import as text files in the
ingenuity this path often ranged in size
that can be quite large with the over
1,500 genes to analyze to avail
ourselves of the gene agnostic features
in the unity we need a thorough
description of the clinical phenotype of
the patient for that we use phenotypes
which is an open source web-based
application for standard phenotyping
using a human phenotype ontology
ontology or HBO
terms this term provides us with the
information we need to enable us to use
the phenotype and phenotype trimmed
ranking analysis in immunity when
analyzing cases in unity we have set up
standard filters at the in templates
these filter settings were adjusted to
our requirements from the default
settings the filter cascade in the
ingenuity is the linear
this requires shuffling of the filters
for full analysis to access the
different gene panels and also the
phenotype panels sometimes though we can
use both filters in conjunction and to
hone in on a variant of interest the
power of the dual gene panel and gene
agnostic approach leads to more
potential cost in variants being
identified the palace and phenotype
results mostly overlap but the phenotype
analysis could bring to light
differential diagnosis which may not
have been obvious to the clinician at
the time of our examination after
filtering in immunity
the result is exported as VCF files and
imported into our in-house system where
we annotate and classified the remaining
candidate variants as this is a clinical
service these exported VCF files are
saved together with those cases specific
filter settings for audit purposes in
maka then we can collect all information
regarding the case in one place and the
system is designed for a seamless
workflow and even scientist to take over
from each other and continue to process
cases rather than once
just working on a case from start to
finish and they found this to be very
beneficial to a smooth workflow and
service ingenuity clicks bind
information from a number of sources
some which are presented directly and
some which are linked to the premiere
feature is a forced acknowledge space
that enables the phenotype and phenotype
driven ranking analysis we use the ACMG
classification provided in ingenuity
with caution as not all evidence is
always applicable to specific cases and
some evidence can be missing we will now
move on to the clinical cases the first
case is the straightforward analysis
where we identified a potentially
causative variant in the primary panel
in this case there was strictly no need
for the phenotype analysis but it was
used anyways to narrow down the search
this slide shows a patient with
suspected donna faro syndrome or
Parature winter syndrome where we
identified a frameshift variant in the
act PT here we can see that we went from
12 eggs in the primary panel down to one
hits when used in conjunction with the
phenotype Mouse's
when this result was brought to the
clinic for our mix the Disciplinary team
meeting the referring clinician agreed
that the gene was a good fit for the
clinical phenotype we sang and confirmed
the variant improvement and parents and
after confirming parentage we were able
to add the PST criteria to the
classification some of you might have
spotted there that the classification on
the previous slides didn't quite add up
in this case highlights the speed at
which a case can be solved unfortunately
it's not always that easy as we can see
in this case we often come up empty
despite analyzing large gene panels plus
using phenotype and ranking analysis
this slide shows a patient with several
phenotypic features but nothing of
interest but that was identified in any
of the analysis although having all
these analyst analyzes together in
Indonesia makes it certain that you have
left no stone unturned in the third case
we found nothing of interest in the
primary panel but pickable picked up an
interesting variant using phenotype
analysis here we see a patient with
cerebellar atrophy and the referring
clinician choose a panel associated with
cerebellar hypoplasia in the phenotype
analysis we then identified a topic for
a missense variant the top for a gene
mind turned out to be associated to a
similar phenotype as the one described
in our case and the variant was
confirmed the NoHo this case highlights
the difficulty of selecting the correct
panels even for highly trained
because geneticist and the power of the
phenotype analysis in our fourth and
final case we found no variance of
interest in either the tunnels or in the
phenotype analysis this slide shows a
patient with suspected that hell is a
Smurfs Parker disease and none of the
selected genes had any variants however
as you can see in the screenshots and
performing the phenotype gem in ranking
we picked up to suspect variants in the
same game SOC 1785 it turns out that the
phenotype associated the two as I'll see
something a 5/5 well with our patient
and the Barons were confirmed to be in
trance this case again highlights the
power of the phenotype and phenotype
type determined ranking and how it can
assist you in finding a diagnosis
together with the information in the
knowledge base
in conclusion we use ingenuity with a
combination of gene panels and phenotype
analysis in our accredited West clinical
service together with a close
collaboration with the clinical team and
at Guy's clinical genetics department we
have achieved what we feel is a high
diagnostic rate this is our team West
here admire us and now we'd like to open
up to the live Q & A session thank you
thank
Bastien for a great presentation we now
have time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button and the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for okay we
can get started our first question is
what impact be using in the Nexus and
can I be a have on your team's daily
work how our youth are you using the
time you're staring any takers for this
question or unity ingenuity we use that
excel very filtered and applied in
panels so in the move to ingenuity
really helped us with their their the
workflow that they have and the filters
that you can adjust in real time and
like more panels and of course the
phenotype is Argentina type hidden'
ranking that we didn't have access to
previously this was really beneficial to
our workflow and at the time it takes to
analyze the case of course but the extra
time that we saved
we used to analyze more cases from Alex
point of view I'd say I think just
having our whole pipeline automated has
just freed up a lot of time to do more
development work so we're sort of
commonly working up new oncology
pipelines or looking at new technologies
such as Oxford nanopore it's just freed
up a lot of time to to develop those
really if it escapes thanks mate Thanks
ambient our next question is which tools
are you using for semantic variant :
so for EGFR pipeline that we've got at
the moment we're using our scan and
bardet for variant calling so you're on
both of them and the current my
scientist in interpretation initially
look at fast scan but I think they found
that bardic sometimes calls in Dells or
reliably so if they don't find very no
interested in from the bar scan results
then they'll go and look at the Barnack
data yeah I should probably just add
that pipeline is for tumor samples only
and we are working on tumor normal
analysis joint somatic German analysis
as well and for analysis mentioned is to
my only Facebook and thanks Andy
next question what fraction of your
samples are FFP derived and do you have
a dedicated QC tool there the moment I
think all of samples are FFP we don't
currently have any specific QC tools
from in the bio informatics pipeline or
FFPE samples
I believe the success rate is something
like 98% is what we're saying I think
most recently heard so we don't get a
high failure rate or anything with the
FFPs
yes so that's for the EGFR test the FFPE
samples that go for genome sequencing do
have a fairly high failure rate and as
part of the hundred thousand genomes
project there's been quite a lot of work
done to see if using fresh frozen tumor
samples gives you
much better success rates and the
utility of downstream in the analysis
over enthalpy yeah thanks Luke thanks
Andy looks like we still have time for
one last question
those whose questions we haven't had
time for please know we'll be following
up with you by email okay so our last
question for today how do you see the
clinical genomics market growing in UK
and Europe any takers
well so in the UK specifically the
genetics services in the NHS are going
through a wheat procurement process
there is a desire to do some
consolidation there are over 20 H and n
Eastern approaches in England alone and
we are hoping that by introducing sense
of consolidation across those
laboratories it will generate some
savings which we can invest into
bringing on new technologies such as
genome sequencing and try and make that
routine on a routine care so in terms of
what's going to happen so by passionate
abortions is expecting to see quite
significant growth finally because of
that consolidation that's happening in
the country but also there is a a drive
destroying mainstream genetics further
so that specialties that haven't
traditionally sent patients in for
genetic testing we'll have that
available to them and be able to take
advantage of that so there are some
activity projections for the next few
years for the UK and they show quite
significant growth yeah
that's fantastic thanks Luke yeah this
was the end of our Q&A I would like to
once again thank the bypass team left to
right Matthias Ian stone and rebound a
Jew who aDNA for the great presentation
in their time do you have any final
comments no just great thank you for
having us in pleasure to show everyone
how we work and then how we've taken
advantage of and the power levels are
out there and available thanks and
thanks again to the whole bag of team if
you like more information on how to gain
the Nexus platform it can be used to run
clinical grade pipelines in the [ __ ]
compliant environment but if you'd like
to know more about hyejin's ingenuity
variant analysis economic interpretation
you may email me directly at any company
and in the Nexus calm before we go I
want to let everybody know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing for six months from today's like
the belt will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please do
share this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
leti bet the soul for now thank you so
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye